warzone season 5 has been rough
what is that there are tons of graphical
glitches but hey they made for some
funny moments
let's take a look back at a few from
this week
that's all we've ever wanted uh okay
let's try that again number five
the upside down reddit user crushed
muffins just wants to relax and play a
game of warzone but his pc would rather
not
bro what am i dealing with today after
failing to fully load in the map
he somehow is able to land on the train
but things go even further south when he
tries to aim down the sights of his gun
[Music]
oh my god look at him look at what it
looks like when i scope in
this glitch is pretty common so let's
hope for a hotfix soon
that being said should we do a potato
mode with warzone
number four the ghost and ghost lego
myego here spots a wild ghost with no
one around him
so he goes for the rpg kill but then
what's this
what happened where did he go let's
watch again
it looked like a direct hit the eod
indicator even went off
but sure enough he's gone there's no
sign of him
i think it's safe to say that this ghost
went dark
number three the new operator after
wrapping it up at a buy station
this unlucky fellow immediately gets
shot by who you ask
um this thing
how can you even see what you're
shooting
oh you can't couldn't have said it
better myself
number two born to lose urban pod from
reddit uploaded this clip of him diving
into a game of warzone
and everything seems okay until he lands
with nothing but his fists
before he can find a gun or even
encounter another player
he's sent straight to the gulag you win
this fight
it's like he started a round of war zone
and his pc said you lose
good day sir number one the hack
clap back on one of his live streams
hedy and his squad were pinned on a roof
with an enemy hacker below
after being down in the overtime final
circle his team has no choice but to
jump
using a hail mary c4 his team kills the
hacker and they win the game
with others spectating this awesome win
it's needless to say that the post game
comes were hot
let's listen
if i close my eyes i feel like i'm back
in a modern warfare 2 lobby
for your bonus clips of the week we have
marcus aka leonardo here with a fun
back-to-back team wipe using his swords
and a perfectly tossed c4
very nice last but not least we have
puppy paws
she's a nearly blind player who gets a
sweet kill inside one of the skyscrapers
i got him oh [ __ ] i had my sniper up
whoops nice job i still can't no scope
even on accident
if you'd like a chance to see your clip
here let me know on twitter thanks for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you